weil tankret Stübe bei uns ist und ich
glaube ist der ideale Mann um uns einmal
mitzunehmen rein in die Situation Israel
Gaza das ist sozusagen der eine
Kriegsschauplatz über den wir heute
sprechen wollen der zweite ist die
Ukraine
Herr Stübe
ich ich habe sie vorhin zitiert die
humanitäre Situation ist eine
Katastrophe die medizinische Versorgung
ist eine Katastrophe was erzählen ihen
ihre Kollegen Freunde Ärzte Ärztinnen
die dort Dienst tun und unter welchen
Umständen tun sie den gerade also ist
eine absolute Fassungslosigkeit und
Ohnmacht da bei allen unseren Leuten wir
haben 300 palästinensische
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in Gaza
wir haben ungefähr im Moment 15
internationale die neu reingekommen sind
wir weitere Teams in Standby die auch
nach Gaza gehen würden wenn die
Sicherheit wenn die zollpassagen die
Versorgungslage sich die Sicherheitslage
sich bessern würde es ist einfach
absolut katastrophal wir hatten am 6
dezember in einem der Kliniken die wir
unter Stützen im Süden von Gaza hatten
wir an 24 Stunden mehr Tote über 100
Tote eingeliefert in diese Klinik als
verletzte und das ist so ein bisschen
sinnbildlich dafür das ist das
Verhältnis mehr Tote als verletzte genau
das ist jetzt nicht jeden Tag das war an
diesem einen 6 Dezember so
die Kliniken sind fast dysfunktional aus
vielerlei Gründen es gibt zu wenig
Medikamente zu wenig medizinisches gerad
es gibt kein Strom also Mangel an allen
Ecken und wenig Ärzte pflegende und es
gibt ein ein absolut
uten ja Run auf diese Kliniken von
Schwerstverletzten die dann nicht äquat
versorgt werden können die es oft gar
nicht mehr diese Kliniken schaffen weil
sie vorher umkommen oder weil die Wege
zu den Kliniken zerstört sind wie wird
denn da operiert unter solchen Umständen
das ist im Moment alles was wir machen
können ist ein Tropfen auf dem heißen
Stein das heißt sehr sehr viele Menschen
erreichen die Kliniken nicht sie werden
dort nicht mehr adäquat versorgt es gibt
nicht adäquat
Medikamente um diese Menschen versorgen
zu können und äh ja seit seit Tagen seit
Wochen gibt es den klaren Appell von Arz
und Grenzen aber auch vom
Internationalen Roten Kreuz un und so
weiter dass diese massenhaften
Bombardierung in Gaza in einem der
dichtesten
bevölkertsten gegenen dieser Welt
aufhören muss also es kann nicht sein
dass Menschen die
mit der Politik nichts am Hut haben die
mit diesem Konflikt nichts am Hut haben
dort ihre Leben lassen müssen also
insofern der dringende Appell dass das
wirklich dieses flächendeckende und so
muss man es einfach beschreiben
flächendeckes deckendes äh
B wenn da operiert wird noch mal wie
wird das gemacht also Amputationen ist
ja ein riesiges Thema in Kriegsgebieten
in der Ukraine ja beispielsweise auch
haben Sie die Medikamente dafür um
Menschen zu narkotisieren oder ähnliche
Dinge genau es ist schwierig weil ja
immer wieder Stromausfälle da sind
normalerweise diese diese Krankenhäuser
dort alle Arbeiten mit Backup mit
Generatoren weil immer gibt es in Gaser
seit vielen Jahren gibt es Stromausfälle
ich habe sie immer wieder erlebt ich war
zweimal dort habe dort gearbeitet das
heißt das normale in Gaza ist
Stromausfall Generator
genauze auf den intensivation aber auch
für die OP für das Licht für die
Gerätschaften dort und
jetzt gibt's eben kein kein Diesel kein
Benzin weil das seit seit Wochen nicht
mehr nach Gaser reinkommt das heißt die
Generatoren funktionieren nicht mehr
dann wird versucht sich zu behelfen
indem man eben ja die die Mobiltelefone
die die Telefone die das Licht nimmt um
zu Licht zu machen
t für die OP man versucht die
Medikamente zu verdünnen man versucht
irgendwo und im Zweifelsfall dann eben
auch mal ohne Narkose oder ohne
Schmerzmittel zu
behandeltieren unsere Ärzte im Moment
berichten das nicht aber ich kenne
glaubwürdige Berichte von Kolleginnen
und Kollegen in den letzten Wochen also
die Situation ist einfach unerträglich
und
auch das was jetzt reinkommt an
Hilfsmitteln sind ja in normalen Zeiten
in Gaser pro Tag rund bis zu 500 LKW
Ladungen weil der Gaser ist komplett
abhängig von äußerer Hilfe das Land ist
zu klein um sich selber am Leben zu
erhalten das heißt im Moment sind es mal
ein Dutzend ja das heißt die Nöte die
medizinischen die Versorgungs die Essens
die Vorrats die trinknöte gehen hoch die
Versorgungslage geht runter und diese
extreme Spanne die da aufgeht die ist
unerträglich und sie ist
tödlich Herr Kiesewetter ähm die Frage
nach der Verhältnismäßigkeit
über die haben wir relativ lange äh
nicht gesprochen auch in deutschen
Medien immer sehr vorsichtig darüber
gesprochen wir beide haben hier auch
häufiger gesessen haben die Frage
erörtert wenn Israel deutsche
staatsreson ist was bedeutet das und sie
haben mir damals erklärt
notfalls bedeutet das dass
äh auch wenn der Bundestag dem zustimmt
dass auch mus die Deutche Bundeswehr
notfalls da rein ja aber jetzt wird
plötzlich die Frage nach der
Verhältnismäßigkeit gestellt und ich
habe das Gefühl es hat sich etwas
verändert jetzt nach dieser dieser
Feuerpause sammeln sich die Menschen im
Süden im Süden fast 2 Millionen Menschen
die dort auf engstem Raum auf der Flucht
unterernährt wirklich also hungrig
medizinisch völlig unterversorgt das zu
Hause nicht mehr vorhanden und dann
gehst du da rein mit Bombardements ist
das
verhältnismäßig will das sehr klar sagen
auch wenn es weh tut verursache ist die
Hamas die Hamas wollte diese Bilder
produzieren und sie tut alles dass
Israel diese Bild er produziert die
Rechnung der Hamas geht auf in der Art
und Weise wie Israel nicht akzeptieren
kann dass die Hamas weiter existiert und
dafür werden die Einwohnerinnen und
Einwohner des Gazastreifens nicht als
Schutzschilde sondern in die Geiselhaft
der Hamas genommen diese mehreren
tausend Menschen der militärische Arm
der Hamas die politische Kaste die seit
1987 sich gegründet hat hat hunderte
Millionen Hilfsgelder man spricht von
bis zu 2 Milliarden alles auf die Seite
und deswegen dürfen wir uns nicht von
diesen Bildern ausschließlich verleiten
lassen weil wir gar nicht mehr darüber
reden was für ein Leid Israel angetan
wurde entscheidend ist jetzt dass Israel
versteht lassen Sie mich das zu Ende
israel muss begreifen dass die Rechnung
der Hamas aufgeht Israel international
zu isolieren und jetzt kommt es darauf
an dass Israel die noch verbleibende
Zeit nutzt verhältnismäßig ist
juristisch definiert und das versteht
unter der emotionalen aufgeladenheit
niemand ist es erforderlich ist es
wirksam ist es verhältnismäßig im Sinne
und da gibt es aus Afghanistan Beispiel
das bedeutet dass sie noch mehrere
Wochen haben und dies durchzuführen und
dann werden die Karten neu gemischt und
dann heißt es dass ein
netanahu ein Netanyahu hat das die
Endzeit seiner Regierung erreicht es ist
nicht mehr akzeptabel dass ein
Regierungschef die notwendigen Warnungen
im Vorfeld ignoriert hat Netanyahu hat
jetzt auch die Aufgabe dass sich der
Konflikt nicht aufs westjordan
es muss ein prozessfunden werden dass
die Siedlungen rückgebaut werden im
Westjordanland um den palätinensern
überhaupt eine Perspektive zu geben aber
wir müssen ganz unnachsichtig ganz
unnachsichtig die Hamas bekämpfen denn
da steht der Iran dahinter da steht
Russland dahinter und die beiden haben
natürlich ein ganz großes Interesse die
westliche Welt zu diskreditieren weil
wir Israel als verbliebene Demokratie in
der Region natürlich verteidigen und das
ist die emotionale aufgeladenheit in der
Situation deswegen sage ich ja es gilt
Israel umfassend zu unterstützen im
Kampf gegen Hamas sie kann sofort
aufhören sie können Ihre Terroristen
ausliefern sie können sofort aufhören zu
kämpfen wenn Israel aufhört zu kämpfen
ist das Existenzrecht Israels bedroht
und der Zweck der Hamas ist nicht die
Verteidigung Gaza der Zweck der Hamas
ist die Vernichtung Israels und das
machen sie völlig schlimm mit diesen
furchtbaren Bildern und dies zu
überwinden das ist diplomatische Kunst
die uns alle noch in den nächsten
Monaten massiv fordern wird aber ich
glaube ich muss hier trotzdem
wiederprechen ich würde mich als Arzt
nicht in die Politik einmischen die so
komplex ist dass wir sie alle kaum
ertragen trotzdem ist die Frage dass
jetzt in wenigen Wochen und die Zahlen
sind relativ glaubhaft 17 000 Menschen
in Gaza ums Leben gekommen sind und die
Mehrheit und auch das ist glaubhaft sind
Zivilisten sind Frauen Kinder
unschuldige Menschen und das geht jeden
Tag weiter und das ist nicht tolerabel
und da gibt es für mich auch kein
politische Ausrede dass das weitergehen
kann das ist keine Ausrede sind ganz
klar Bekenntnis die Verbrechen die von
Gaza ausgegangen sind müssen gesühnt
werden die Opfer sind die Bevölkerung es
ist die Hamas die diese Opfer verursacht
die Israelis stützen sich hier auch auf
Zahlen die die Hamas veröffentlicht und
wenn wir in solche Dinge schauen wird
immer nach Verhältnismäßigkeit geschaut
nur müssen wir begreifen dass das
israelische Militär pro hamasführer 30
40 Tote akzeptiert und das furchtbare
ist wenn dann mehrere zusammenkommen
dass Israel in seiner güterabwegung sie
das richtig ich sage nur so ist es würde
ger und das
Kenan ich finde es dahingehend richtig
dass wir das unserer Bevölkerung
erklären ich selbst habe das in
Afghanistan erlebt bis 2007 als die
Amerikaner bis zu 20 kollateraltte pro
hochwertziel in anführungstrichen wie
sie das furchtbarerweise nanden
akzeptiert haben und dann hunderte
zivile Opfer entstanden sind und dann
die Glaubwürdigkeit der Amerikaner
gelitten hat und jetzt leidet die
Glaubwürdigkeit der Israelis gleich wohl
ihr Existenzrecht bedroht ist und das
muss diplomatisch überwunden werden
wo sind die Araber die sagen wir helfen
den Palästinensern wo ist die
internationale Gemeinschaft die deutlich
macht dass Israel das Opfer war das
fehlt mir in der ganzen Debatte ich
möchte gar nicht und auch er Grenzen wir
haben sofort am 7 machen das sehr gut
übrigens am 7 oktober hat Erz Grenzen
sofort Israel auch Hilfe angeboten aber
das israelische Gesundheitssystem gehört
zu den besten der Welt verstehen wir
dass Sie unsere Hilfe nicht brauchen
also sie haben das abgelehnt oder Sie
haben darauf nicht groß reagiert und das
ist für uns auch nachvollziehbar wir
insistieren ja nicht in einem Land zu
helfen wenn da die Hilfe nicht nötig ist
und das ist auch relativ nachvollziehbar
dass dass das exzellente
Gesundheitssystem in Israel dass die das
selber soweit geschafft haben was wir
aber sehen dass jetzt in Gaza wo es
keine Klinik mehr gibt die nicht
entweder direkt oder indirekt massiv von
diesen Bombardements betroffen ist dass
tausende Menschen sterben das
unschuldige die und ich war zweimal hab
zweimal 2005 und 18 in Gasa gearbeitet
wir sind ja täglich im Gespräch mit mit
den Patientinen mit den Patienten mit
unseren
Mitarbeitenden die große Mehrheit mit
den Menschen denen ich gesprochen hab
denen ist Politik egal den ist die Hamas
egal sie haben ja oft gar keine
Wahlmöglichkeiten sie wollen überleben
sie wollen ihr normales Leben führen und
das ist im Moment nicht mehr möglich es
gibt keinen Platz kein Quadratmeter in
Gasa der noch sicher ist ich würde gerne
noch mal Herr Kiesel sie haben vorhin
gesagt dieses Verhältnis wird mich noch
mal interessieren sag wie viele tote
Zivilisten ist man bereit in Kauf zu
nehmen als Kollateralschaden für einen
hamasäh ich mag den Ausdruck
Kollateralschaden nicht ich weiß nur
dass die israelischen Streitkräfte
ählich ja ich wen i auch nicht ich weiß
nur dass die israelischen Streitkräfte
ähnlich wie viele andere Streitkräfte in
der Welt auch das Stichwort
Verhältnismäßigkeit prüfen nach ist es
erforderlich es zu tun ja die Hamas zu
bekämpfen ist es wirksam das sieht man
und ist es verhältnismäßig und das
werden Gerichte entscheiden mü wie ist
das Verhältnis gerade und das ist schwer
rauszurechnen wir haben in dem was wir
untersucht was wir untersucht haben
könnte das ein zu 30 sein ein zu 30
könnte das Verhältnis sein 30 Tote für
einen toten Terroristen das sind im im
militärischen Bereich immer wieder
abwegungen die dann auch politisch
gebilligt und gedeckt werden müssen nun
ist sie israel fühlt sich in der
Existenz ja nicht nur bedroht sie sind
bedroht und das müssen wir mit unserem
westlichen Bedenken mit unserem
westlichen Bedenken und denken auch
berücksichtigen hier geht es darum der
Hamas keine Überlebenschance zu geben
weil das sonst eine Einladung für
Hisbollah und dem Iran ist und es ist
auch eine furchtbare Abschreckung und
das bedeutet auch dass die Palästinenser
sich von dieser fatalen Führung befreien
müssen aber was erreicht man wenn man
bereit ist 30 Tote Frauen und Kinder und
Jugendliche in Kauf zu nehmen die mit
Hamas die mit Politik im Grunde nichts
zu tun haben damit man einen von der
Hamas bekommt züchtet man da nicht
Terroristen in einer Anzahl nach wie man
sich das nicht hat vorstellen öffnet man
damit nicht die Tore zur Hölle wie es
jemand im Zusammenhang mit dem Irakkrieg
mal gesagt hat wir waren schon mal viel
weiter und wir müssen immer auch nach
Ursache und Wirkung schauen wenn wir
jetzt auf diese Wirkung schauen dann ist
natürlich Israel extrem unter der Kritik
keiner redet mehr darüber wie furchtbar
brutal dieas vorging nein ich spreche
das bewusst an und das ist jetzt die
Folge wenn sie sich when aber sie sagen
selber Herr kiesbert ich zitiere sie das
ist nicht mehr verhältnismäßig was da
passiert ich zitiere sie nicht
irgendjemand anderen aber der der der
Punkt ist wie soll Israel aus dem
Dilemma herauskommen das bedarf einer
ganz starken Rückendeckung für Israel
und nicht eine Isolierung in den
Vereinten Nationen die aus ausgesprochen
Palästinenser freundliche Resolutionen
wir reden wir reden um das auch noch mal
klar zuuziehen ne her tan wir reden
jetzt über Kritik an israelischer
Politik und auch über Kritik an jemanden
wie Netanyahu jemand von dem mein Gefühl
mir sagt das ist der erste der am 7
Oktober eigentlich hätte zurücktreten
müssen ja
absolut der der 7 Oktober der 7 Oktober
war der Angriff ein der terroristischen
Organisation nicht sagen dass verursacht
hat ne übrigens
aber ja das hier so nebenbei gefallen
ist ich würde nicht sagen dass netanahu
das verursacht hat möchte sehr deutlich
sagen dass netanahu die israelische
Gesellschaft nicht nur gespalten hat
sondern die Aufmerksamkeit Israels auf
innenpolitische ja Befindlichkeiten mit
einer rechtsradikal geführten Regierung
konzentriert hat eine Regierung die ihm
verhindert dass er ins Gefängnis muss
dass er vor Gericht gestellt wird dieses
hat das Land gespitert und durch seine
Art und Vorgehensweise hat er nicht die
notwendigen Meldungen akzeptiert israel
hat insbesondere weibliche whrpflichtige
sehr früh auf die Änderung am
Gasastreifen hingewiesen und in seiner
Regierung gab es nicht das Klima das
aufzugreifen ich habe war in der her
Konferenz ich hab das selbst vor Ort
gespüt wie zerrissen diese Regierung war
vor wenigen Monaten vor vor diesem
Angriff im Mai und im Juni und das
Entscheidende ist dass dieser Netanyahu
seine Gesellschaft gespalten hat und
viele aus den Nachrichtendiensten aus
dem Sicherheitskräften sich
verabschiedet haben aus der
Unterstützung is immer Teil im Zusam
Regung die Verantwortung übernehmen und
es muss auch geprüft werden welche
Meldungen lagen vor und es geht mir
darum dass Israel wieder eine
regelbasierte Regierung bekommt die
nicht provoziert in Jerusalem die die
Frage der Siedler in westjordan endlich
im Sinne der Palästinenser löst und die
Siedler in das eigene Land zurückführt
aber der eben auch klar macht das was
Hamas gemacht hat ist ein furchtbares
Verbrechen und dies muss gesühnt werden
und die Hamas darf nicht überleben okay
ist trotzdem interessant ihre
Formulierung sie sagten gerade der hat
ursacht er ist dam mit
Hauptverantwortliche dass das passiert
ist weil dieser Pearl Harbor Effekt
durch die durch ihn verursachte
Blindheit entstanden ist okay ich würde
da trotzdem immer das ist interessant da
sind wir jetzt ganz weit auseinander
gerade ich würde da immer massiv
wiedersprechen weil die Entscheidung am
7 oktober in Südisrael so reinzugehen
und das zu tun was man da tut die trifft
am Ende die Hamas ganz alleine und das
macht do jeder einzelne der damit dabei
ist triff diese Entscheidung auch ganz
hab dieses Klima geschaffen dass die
Hamas Israel schwach wähnte das Israel
dachte Israel ist schwach das können wir
tun sie sind ja mit diesen furchtbaren
Bildern bestätigt worden ein
sicherheitsversagen in Israel gewesen
ohne Ende gut interessanter
Punkt der Angriff vom 7 Oktober war der
Angriff von Hamas Terroristen mit
Unterstützung Vorbereitung aus dem Iran
da gab es eine internationale Verbindung
selbstverständlich aber netanahu ist
derjenige ich ich würde ihn nicht als
einen Verursacher oder ich würde sagen
einen Ermöglicher inoweit als er eben
einfach seine
kentriert hat seine Kräfte darauf
konzentriert hat und Sicherheitskräfte
im Westjordanland um Siedler auf nicht
israelischen Boden zu verteidigen und
dafür Israelis auf israelischenem Boden
am Gazastreifen in Stich gelassen und da
bin ich bei der Frage was schadet
eigentlich Israel was bedroht eigentlich
Israel und da muss man wirklich sagen es
ist die Politik dieses Premierministers
der über eine sehr lange Zeit er regiert
ja nicht das erste Mal
jetzt sondern genau wir kennen ihn aus
den 90er Jahren und es ist jemand der
einfach in seiner Zeit immer stärker die
Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde
bekämpft hat als tatsächlich die
hamasterroristen der sich auch über die
Hamas wie geäußert hat so so sinngemäß
eigentlich gut dass wir die haben weil
dann solange die nicht zusammenarbeiten
also vertach und Hamas kurzem hat er
noch gesagt er würde niemals der
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde äh zu
zulassen dass die in Gaza regieren also
er schwächt sozusagen die Alternative zu
den hamasterroristen wie er nur kann und
er tut noch etwas anderes und das da
wiesen sie ja eben auch schon drauf hin
ich glaube dass er Israel eben
tatsächlich nach innen komplett
gespalten hat in einer sehr kritischen
Situation ähm er ist und da komme ich
jetzt auf die was sie vorhin erwähnten
Brüder im Geist ich glaube er ist ein
Bruder im Geiste von Vladimir Putin weil
er eben tatsächlich diesen autoritären
Weg den er eingeschlagen hat und wo er
versuchte halt eben tatsächlich den
israelischen Rechtsstaat auszuhebeln das
ist ja genau die Art und Weise wie
Vladimir Putin mal angefangen hat der
fing an beim Verfassungsgericht der fing
an eben bei den bei den gesetzlichen bei
der Justiz und bei den checks and
balances in Russland nach den
demokratischen gversuchen Russlands in
den 90er Jahren da schoss Putin genau in
diese in die Beine so wie Netanyahu das
jetzt versucht hat im ablaufenden Jahr
und da muss man dann tatsächlich sagen
und auch dran erinnern wie es gab ja
einen solidaritätsanruf aus der Ukraine
sehr interessant von selenski der rief
sofort am 7 Oktober an und sagte ich
komme vorbei
Solidaritätsadresse Netanyahu hat es
abgelehnt und dann hat er einfach über
eine Woche auf einen Anruf von Vladimir
Putin gewartet der nicht angerufen hat
und dann als sie endlich telefonierten
nachdem Netanyahu insistieren ließ durch
seine Berater dann hat er dann so eine
lauwarme Erklärung abgegeben dabei hatte
Putin sich natürlich schon längst
eingebucht bei den und weltweiten
Unterstützern von Hamas und Gaza mit
Leningrad verglichen z.B was übrigens
Israel auf die Blockade der durch die
nationalso und das ist deshalb so
schlimm er hat in Gaza mit Leningrad in
einer Zeit verglichen wo Russland aktiv
versucht die Leningrader Blockade
international als Genozid anerkennen zu
lassen mit anderen Worten Gaza sei
Genozid das ist das was Putin behauptet
und mit so einem versucht Netanyahu die
ganze Zeit und er hat noch nicht damit
aufgehört er hofft die ganze Zeit noch
auf Putin
und dabei hat der ihn sowas von im Regen
stehen lassen und ganz Israel mit ja
beides wird für die deutsche Politik ein
riesen Problem denn das die Position die
sie vertreten ist ja auch das was man
aus der Ampel immer gehört hat also mm
dieses insistieren wir stehen
unverbrüchlich an der Seite Israels
Komma egal wie schlimm die Bilder werden
das ist der Satz den ich aus den ersten
Tagen immer wieder ihr müsst dann auch
bereit sein das auszuhalten ich auch
hierulier das ist also nach dem genau
das was man am häufigsten gehört hat was
auch allen Verantwortlichen klar war das
wird nicht schön werden ist
also so genau und am 7 oktober hat da
würde ich auch immer sagen muss man in
Deutschland klar machen die Hamas die
die Tore der Hölle geöffn
sagen will aber für die deutschen
Verantwortlichen wird es natürlich
schwieriger weil man in Netanyahu einen
Partner hat von dem man auch unter der
Hand immer mal hört wie gefährlich der
ist der nämlich innen poliitisch nichts
mehr zu verlieren hat und wie wir wissen
sind alle Politiker die unter Druck
stehen sehr bereit
außenpolitisch anders und auch
verheerend zu wirken es ist für
Deutschland ein Problem das so
forzuführen denke ich in den nächsten
Wochen trotzdem also kann ich als Bürger
dieses Landes dem ja nur zustimmen
natürlich kann ich als Deutscher Israel
nicht das Existenzrecht
abtimmen das steht immer vor der Klammer
aber wir reden über die
verhälmä passier reden Entschuldigung
nur ganz kurz um das einmal klar
zuziehen Herr Stö wir reden darüber was
eigentlich schon einer der allerersten
gedankenformulierungen von Tony blinken
dem amerikanischen Außenminister war der
sagte selbstverständlich Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung aber über die Frage
wie das geschieht darüber müssen wir
reden und diese und diese Appelle diese
Warnungen werden lauter und sie werden
deutlicher und was wir jetzt jeden Tag
und das ist mein Punkt was wir jetzt
jeden Tag sehen das geht eben über eine
abstrakte und eine auch natürlich
historisch begründete Unterstützung
hinaus wir sehen jeden Tag hunderte
Menschen in Gaza die nicht durch eine
Lawine oder sonst was durch Leben konnen
sondern die durch bombenbeschuss durch
Leben ums Leben kommen die unschuldig
sind und da muss das muss aufhören und
die die Wege die Israel die israelische
Führung da findet das das müssen die ne
das ist als als humanitärer Arzt kann
ich dazu nicht sagen aber das Leid in
Gaza das ist nicht rechtfertigbar was da
passiert und das geht jeden Tag weiter
und wir wissen nicht wie lange und die
Menschen haben keine Überlebenschance in
Gaza und das sie sagen man darf sich von
den Bildern nicht erschrecken lassen
oder sowas aber Entschuldigung also sich
davon nicht mitnehmen zu lassen was da
gerade passiert m dann dann dann müssen
wir Roboter dahin schicken ja aber als
als als mit der Arzt der diese Menschen
kennt in Gaza kann ich nur sagen das
kann so nicht weitergehen ist weg und es
ist jeden Tag und das ist ne wir sehen
solche solche Szenarien sehen wir sonst
vielleicht in Kriegen und da kommen wir
ja nachher noch mal drauf in der Ukraine
wo wir sagen ja da haben wir es mit
Regime zu tun mit denen wir es
vielleicht noch schwieriger haben
aber was in Gaza passiert dieses
massenbombardement von Menschen die
nichts mit diesem Konflikt zu tun haben
und auch nichts zu tun haben wollen das
muss aufen ich hab bevor wir gleich zu
Ukraine kommen Herr kiesewit an sie zwei
Fragen das eine ist ähm 16 17 000
menschenm sind mutmaßlich in Gaza
gestorben die Israelis die israelische
Armee sagt ungefähr zwei Drittel davon
sind Zivilisten sind Menschen die mit
diesem Krieg nichts zu tun haben das
heißt in wenigen Wochen in 7 Wochen sind
in Gaza so viele Zivilisten gestorben
wie in knapp zwei Jahren in der Ukraine
um mal die Verhältnismäßigkeit klar zu
machen
ich würde gerne noch auf was anderes
hinaus die israelische Armee ist im
Gegensatz zu putinsarmee eine Armee die
eigentlich dafür bekannt ist zu sagen wo
sie angreift zu warnen wo sie angreift
man nennt das dann ich habe Begriff
bittecking hanocking klopfen aufs Dach
genau klopfen aufs Dach ist sozusagen
die Formulierung sehr interessant nach
der Motte wir schicken erstmal so ein
paar leichtere Dinge rein damit den
Leuten klar ist achtung da passiert's
gleich und dann schicken wir die
schwerere
hinterher was auffällt ist dass das in
diesem Krieg tatsächlich
überproportional wenig passiert das ist
das eine ich lese dass das passiert mit
Unterstützung von KI
beispielsweise KI ist sehr emotionslos
also ne das wenn künstliche Intelligenz
sagt okay da greifst du jetzt bitte an
ich weiß nicht ob man solchen
Information so trauen kann und der
dritte Punkt ist auf den ich gerne
hinaus würde wenn man dann anfängt g und
das scheint ja passiert zu sein in so
Planquadrate einzuteilen und zu sagen
okay da haben wir so hunderte kleiner
Streifen ja und da greifen wir jetzt an
nur damit ihr bescheid wisst also geht
ihr bitte von Streifen a nach Streifen B
und dann greifen wir jetzt bitte
Streifen C an dann denke ich immer wie
soll das unter diesen Umständen
funktionieren wie kann man denn
ernsthaft glauben dass das eine humanere
Art und Weise ist Krieg zu führen wenn
man Menschen 1,8 Millionen irgendwo im
Süden zusammen ficht und dann sagt pass
auf auf Planquadrat a seid ihr jetzt
sicher B greifen wir jetzt bitte in der
nächsten halben Stunde an und danach
bitte wieder zurück auf a weil dann ist
die Sache dort gelaufen ist ja noch eine
andere komponenz werden SMS verschickt
aber natürlich die mögen ja vielleicht
auch die richtigen Nummern haben aber es
gibt kein Stromnetz und kein kein
Mobilfunknetz das heißt die fangen die
gar nicht genau so und da habe ich jetzt
die Frage wenn dieser Krieg und da sind
wir uns glaube ich alle einig ohne Geld
und Waffen aus den USA aber auch aus
Deutschland gar nicht möglich wäre warum
kann man man dann diesem Regierungschef
über den wir gerade gesprochen haben
nicht sagen pass auf entweder hört das
auf oder er kriegt diese Unterstützung
von uns nicht mehr ich sehe das völlig
anders das wäre ein Punkt genaues
Treffen an der genau richtigen Stelle
ich sehe das völlig anders weil das
Israel aus unterschiedlichen Gründen
isolieren würde ich würde auch nicht
Israel man kann Netanyahu mit mit dem
frühen Putin gleichsetzen aber ich würde
Israel nicht mit Russland gleichsetzen
sondern israel ist der Angegriffene ja
Israel ist die Ukraine und Gaza da steht
die Hamas dahinter und steht Iran und
Russland vielle l Verleich
aber ich hab das aber ich möchte das
schon Deich rausstellen das zweite ist
die Zahlen Israel vertuscht nichts das
ist hocherstaunlich h r Jerusalem Post
und andere die bringen sehr deutlich die
Zahlen die israelische Bevölkerung ist
informiert israelischen Medien sind da
auch sehr kritisch und schauen sich die
Sachen genau an das israelische Militär
sagt auch sehr deutlich auch
selbstkritisch dass sie mit dem roof
kncking also nicht nur KI sondern sie
auch Flugblätter abwerfen und vieles
andere nur wir sehen jetzt dass das was
in der Theorie so schön klingt mit der
Vorwarnung und allem in der Praxis
extrem schwer ist nur jetzt schauen wir
mal die Hamas hat angegriffen die Hamas
wird nicht unterstützt von den Ägyptern
die wollen die nämlich gar nicht haben
rich es wäre so leicht gewesen wenn die
Ägypter gesagt hätten wir machen einen
humanitären Korridor wir rufen andere
arabische Staaten zur Hilfe dass die
Sorge von denen dass die Hamas die
Muslimbrüder sind von der Türkei
gestützt werden und vom Iran die die
Ägypter nicht haben wollen weil sie sich
von Muri befreit haben dass sie einen
Korridor schaffen auf dem Sinai der von
den arabischen Staaten mit unterstützt
wird das wä auch ein Zeichen den Abraham
akord ernst zu nehmen wir fokussieren
das ausschließlich auf Israel und
is das ist dieses Abkommen
Friedensabkommen Marok Sudan mit Israel
dass sie das Existenzrecht Israels
anerkennen Sicherheitsgarantien machen
und das entscheidendes ja am 7 oktober
in der Folgewoche sollte der Abraham
Akkord mit Saudiarabien abgeschlossen
werden so und das ist jetzt alles eine
Woche sozusagen vor dem historischen
Schulterschluss Saudiarabien und Israel
greifen die an weil es natürlich Leute
gibt dort offenkundig die gar kein
Interesse und sadad gewesen Ende der
70er Jahre ein historischer
Schulterschluss und der findet nicht
statt das heißt also wir sehen auch wie
isoliert Israel in der Region ist wie
unsicher die Araber sind und jetzt nur
ausschließlich auf Israel zu schauen wir
müssen die Arabische Liga und den
Golfkooperationsrat das sind doch die
Organisation in die Pflicht nehmen es
ist zu billig zu sagen ausschließlich
Israel und auf israelischer Seite Bau
die Kraft der Zivilgesellschaft die nach
diesem Krieg sich sehr deutlich neu
formieren nicht umsonst hat netanahu ja
eine Regierung gebildet wo auch ganz und
und andere mit eingetreten sind dennoch
ähm es geht darum dass wir Israel auch
ermutigen weiterhin humanitäre Korridore
zuzulassen dass weitere Hilfen sind dass
man auch wieder über einen
Waffenstillstand nachdenkt aber dass wir
uns im klar sind unnachsichtig die Hamas
zu bekämpfen okay also tue mich gerade
schwer mit dem Wort mit dem Wort
weiterhin äh die bokabel weiterhin
weiterhin humanitäre Korridore weiterhin
medizinische Unterstützung ich w sagen
schig hilft sind wenig ich h sofort auf
die Waffenruhe wurde durch die Hamas
gebrochen und nicht durch
Israel